[Music]
hello everybody welcome back to the what
podcast i'm barry with me is lord taco
you'll notice that brad is not here uh
hasn't been for a while i don't have we
kicked him out of the club do we want to
kick him out
are we taking a vote is that what we're
doing
oh is anybody care oh
i don't know if anyone cares does
anybody notice no brad is as we've said
many times moved to new york
and
it's caused a little bit of
some scheduling issues but you know
we'll make it work
we have plenty to talk about uh today
and in the coming episodes
right i mean
there's a lot that's happened
in the last year a lot that's happened
then there's a lot that's happened here
in town in chattanooga yeah that i think
you know that's where you and i live
right
that i think relates to festivals in
general and that's why we want to go
ahead and
put an episode out this week
and uh kind of tease what's coming
um i think right in that way i think so
yeah i'm excited for what we've got to
come out here
yeah it's pretty
incredible uh we'll get into it a little
bit but uh
lord taco and i along with brian stone
friend of the show um
we've made fun of brian for six years
right he's our favorite foil i guess
yes
but he was with us he was with you and i
this weekend
we did some interviews we interviewed uh
first of all the mat the moon river
festival was in chattanooga
this weekend which is why we're sort of
ramping things back up
um
you and i and uh brian
spent some time with matt carney
on saturday and uh
also wild rivers that's right
enjoyed talking to
all of them
devin andrew and
khalid from wild rivers and matt
just pryor had a great time down there
saturday despite the misty rain and the
wet conditions
and we were lined up to talk to
what bandera a band of horses with ben
and wild rosado
colorado
we were so excited
about our sunday lineup
and um
you were already there i think you said
you were what two songs into sammy ray
when the
whistle blew
yeah um i got there
you know kicked off around 12 30. uh i
saw maggie rose i walked over and saw
some of abraham alexander with uh
lindsay
and then came back for sammy ray she
just got started played three or four
songs and then made the announcement
that
she had to stop and we had to leave
because there was
lightning and thunderstorms in the area
and so this was around 2 15 to you know
two ish when they when they made the
call
and that's when i texted you and you
were just getting dropped off almost i
was literally pulling into the uber
drop-off line my daughter and son-in-law
and
if i'd have gone another 15 feet i would
have been abandoned
and yeah you sent me the note that they
were clearing the the place out because
of thunderstorms
and that's going to be a um big topic of
a couple of more episodes
for us because i think what
the folks with live nation and c3 and ac
entertainment
and the city of chattanooga and memorial
auditorium the tivoli foundation how
they reacted to what happened on sunday
is uh
it might be one of the great stories in
music festival uh lore at least for
this year and i think so
yeah and if you
organize a festival or want to this is
something to study as far as how to
handle
this is how you do a weather event this
is how you do it yeah we've we've on we
have on this show been critical of the
last two or three four years and uh
um
i won't get too much into it but russ
and i had a conversation with some some
of the folks involved
and i had some off the camera
conversations and this is just how you
do it
uh and let i mean i'll just go ahead and
say it lessons were learned over the
last three or four years
and
they did it right they did some amazing
things but uh
let's just they deserve all the credit
yeah they really did they handled it
right and
uh you know to be fair it's a smaller
festival it's not 80 000 or even 40 000
people but still no it's what it was
about ten thousand about ten right
probably got close and um
you know
they uh two stages
yeah
but they had a tough tough tough
decision you know the
bonnaroo last year was an easy
call once
the call had to be made because
they were literally
six foot you know or not six foot but
six inches 12 inches in water
this was one of those that it
lightning and then it looked like blue
skies and then it got cloudy and then it
rained and you know you're thinking we
can play you know it's classic yeah we
can finish this golf match you know just
keep right whatever yeah and and to be
clear it wasn't just rain it was
lightning and thunder which was the main
concern initially
that's right and yeah it wasn't just
like one storm there was
several around that kept you know poking
their heads out so it was kind of hard
to really get a lot of get a lot of it a
lot of factors how do you get everybody
back in and we'll get into all of that
in detail uh we we have uh
drew holcomb the co-founder of the event
and uh ted heineck with ac entertainment
uh we're gracious enough to get on the
phone with uh russ and i and we're gonna
have that
and then we're gonna talk to some of the
folks at the
local tivolian memorial auditorium
which uh managed to put together a
pretty cool event so we'll get into all
that but um we like i said we wanted to
jump back in we're ready we've got lots
to talk about um i think today you and i
russ we're gonna go ahead and run the
matt carney
interview right um yeah let's get that
going today and uh then we've got more
on the way several more uh interviews
and and stuff to talk about so but you
answered too but yeah i wanted to go
ahead you mentioned lindsay go ahead and
tell everybody who lindsay is because we
ran into several uh
bonnaroo people
yeah
we always run into uh yeah family the
bunner fam when we
do stuff like this but yeah lindsay uh
was awarded bona rouven of the year
earlier if you watch that episode
and um he's the one in in uh
in winchester with the uh you know
12-ish acres of farm that he hosts the
mini-roos that we've had
kind of after bonnaroo got canceled he
was
uh gracious enough to host a few of us
out there to come out and camp and have
a good time so
you know in the absence of two years of
no bonnaroo's we've kind of become
friends and just hung out and talked a
lot so
he came to moon river this year
as a vendor he signed up to work
uh the beard the beer set the beer tent
in vip which he did last year
so
um he came up for that and you know when
when the word came out that we had to
evacuate he and i met up and met up and
went to the gas station bought some beer
and then just sat in the parking garage
next across the street
uh sat on his tailgate and just sat
there and
had a couple beers and hung out played
some music and you know
yeah it was it was honestly fun i mean
you know because what else are you gonna
do
and
i was gonna say brad if he were here
brad has always said as long as i've
known you and brad that taco is the
easiest get-along guy ever
it's like what do you want to do i'm in
whatever so i i was actually telling my
daughter and
son-in-law
you know
tacos in a parking lot drinking a beer
he's having a good time and yeah he said
lindsay's there i'm like yeah he's
having a good time
we weren't suffering that's for sure
we we made the best of it and you know
at this time it
course he had an inside track with
the people with the vendors so he was
communicating with them
and everybody seemed to believe that
well in a couple hours or so this is
going to open back up so we just thought
let's just hang tight let the storm pass
relax and then we'll jump back in and
hopefully see a few more shows
and the word was about 6 or 6 30 we can
go back in well
6 30 came along lindsay went ahead and
went on in because he said well if
they're gonna i probably should help out
and sit up because if they're gonna
reopen you know we'll need to go back to
work
and then he sent me a text a few minutes
later and he said now this thing is not
happening i'm packing up
and so i think that's when i texted you
guys and then i met brian again and told
him yeah i don't think it's happening so
yeah and then a few minutes later that's
when the official word came out that
it's not opening back up
and so that was on sunday
that was sunday and i could see i mean
there was a lot of people around the
entrance just waiting thinking they're
going to get in so
yeah
we've all
i mean you know we've all been at
baseball games where it's a rain delay
and you know you're looking at the sky
and you
there's a lot of factors and and we get
into that with the
ted and drew and we'll talk to uh nick
again but uh
that was sunday but uh let's go back a
little bit to saturday so you and i both
got there about what one o'clock
[Music]
it was a it was i had a good time we did
those two interviews and uh
hung out we talked to the great festival
um we caught bristol maroney's show
there he was great as always yeah he's a
he's a friend of the show three-timer
into the show
uh who else i think i saw i remember i
saw natalie him because hamby was there
yeah
um drew holcomb of course played uh
saturday
yeah we watched drew and ali do
three-legged races because it was their
son's fourth birthday
you'll hear that during the
wild rivers interview uh but yeah it's
it's a neat festival it's a
you know i don't want to get too too
much into it because
you know if you were there you were
there
but it's a it's a boutique festival
which means it's in that
ten to twelve thousand
um
uh
ticketed you know
admission
um yeah very curated you know it's
singer-songwriters yeah
i don't think i don't think they
officially sold out no they didn't
it it sure seemed full i mean it seemed
like a a packed crowd
yeah i was i'm gonna say somewhere
between nine and ten thousand
it it seemed every bit as full as uh
previous years when it was twelve but i
don't know how much of that was because
there was standing water you know and
the crowd wasn't able to you know maybe
be shoulder-to-shoulder but uh
it's a need it's a downtown festival
it's right on the river
you walk in you bike in you uber in
that sort of thing so
it was a lot of fun yeah it's
very accessible being right downtown and
yeah a lot of people will come in just
for the day that's what daniel and
charlotte did
right um come in for the weekend you
could you know get a hotel run an airbnb
because it's not camping
no no
i mean you might you might yeah but no
it's um for the most part if you're from
out of town you get a hotel downtown
and you walk in
i mean that's
part of the the allure
of it really and part of what made
sunday difficult so again we'll get back
into that later that's the pluses and
the minuses but uh yeah
i would say that every bar and
restaurant and shop on the north shore
that sunday probably had a good day
whether they wanted to or not yeah
whether they were suddenly you've got 10
000 people that are just out and are
looking for something to do so yeah
every every little spot was packed and
crowded because people just
didn't want to weren't ready to go home
because we all thought well this is
going to open back up so we'll just hang
out for a few hours
and uh like i said brian uh stone was
kind enough to help us with our shows
and we're going to have him on i hope in
a episode very soon because
i want to hear what he had to say about
saturday and sunday because i think he
went to the event sunday night as you
said so
again there's a lot
i don't mean to short sell
today's
episode uh but we there's really a lot
that happened
on sunday that uh i think is relevant to
this podcast in the industry really
um as as russ said
how they handled it is a you know should
be a road map for
how you should handle these kinds of
things
uh i think so this is right up our alley
i mean this is what we kind of started
the podcast to talk about
exactly but let's go ahead and do this
one uh
i don't i don't know about you matt i
knew a little bit about matt before
saturday but after talking with him uh
cool guy i loved his show i really liked
the uh
paul simon yeah great show
yeah and that that struck me because in
the interview you'll hear him say you
know i think you kind of asked well i
guess you started out playing covers and
and he said no i'm not good at covers i
don't know how i'm you know i just don't
like it
and then to follow that up with we go to
a show and he does a great cover of paul
simon a fairly well-known cover
dancing band members and everything
right i mean choreography he's great
yeah and uh i know i know he endeared
himself to you because he's a he's a vw
guy
apparently so he saw my vw logo on the
shirt and you know asked about that so
we started talking and then uh yeah come
to find out we've all had several
volkswagens yeah all of our first cars
basically were
yeah i had a fastback you had a what was
it i had a i had a notch back and then
he said he had the square back yeah that
was funny so
you never know but he was great uh he's
a eugene oregon guy so the rainy
saturday he was into uh
yeah
he he loved the weather yeah
i liked him i i thought he was great um
only thing that i did here is that he
started his show a little bit early
maybe i think he kicked off uh
before uh was it natalie
i think before natalie ended i think he
sort of
started oh yeah you know
natalie was concluding at 3 30 and he
was supposed to start at 3 30 so did he
i had a couple of fans say why did he
start before she was done but
anyway now we're just picking on stuff
yeah uh but anyway he was great uh
anything else you wanted to mention to
talk about this past weekend like i said
we have so much to unpack
um yeah there's a lot
um
overall it turned into a great weekend
isn't that funny you know i i talked to
brian uh
stone saturday morning i had to go pick
up some recording equipment and it was
you know the weather was iffy
and i think i told him this is either
going to be
the worst day ever or a great day and he
said it's going to be a good day and it
was a great day
it was sunday wasn't it
yeah
[Laughter]
something's happened to that boy i don't
i don't know
i don't know who's gotten a hold of him
because he even on sunday he was like
man i'm so excited to do these
interviews and then we got rained out
um
yep he was upset that we got had our
interviews scrapped but uh you know we
he still ended up having a good time he
he came and hung out with us in the
parking garage for a little bit before
we went in
wow
well had i you know if i got there five
minutes earlier that's probably what i
would have been doing but yeah lindsay
even offered him uh i think he had a
sour and he offered it to brian he said
you want a beer he said oh
what kind is that i'll probably hate it
and he said oh give it to me anyways and
he opened it up and drank it and he
thought
i don't hate that so i don't know what's
going on something is bad bad bad yeah
the curmudgeon is
softening up a little bit definitely but
uh again the reason we you know brad's
not here is we just have so much
information that we need to get to in
the next couple of weeks
and uh we just felt like we needed to go
ahead and get started we did and he will
join us he'll be back in the in the
coming episodes
absolutely i hope he'll be back next
week it's uh
nothing uh other than just scheduling
um yeah
he's got a lot going on and
going to a bunch of
yeah to his credit i mean he's having a
great time in new york his new job is
going really well and he's well we
should probably mention because people
have probably seen it on facebook
his new best friend
um oh yeah yeah his uh his new bff bill
what's his name bill murray said his
name bill murray i think is an actor
an actor yeah it's like an older guy
you've been in a few things you might
have heard yeah
yeah they were hanging out this past
weekend so brad is very busy
um and can't wait to get back from
talking to him and um
talking about uh
i really want to have him uh and he will
join us to talk about
sunday again i keep teasing that
again what c3 and live nation and ac
entertainment and drew holcomb with moon
river uh what they did
it was pretty cool it was very very cool
and they made a yeah they made a whole
lot of people very happy after a
bad situation
so hopefully it'll get a blueprint
i think so and i think that could be the
difference between somebody saying i'm
never coming back to chattanooga versus
i'll be back next year
sure because of how they handled it sure
yeah so we'll we'll leave it there we'll
get to it next week um
but any anything else uh
taco before we
listen to uh
matt carney
yeah let's let's go to matt carney
[Music]
i've known drew for a long time um who
started it and
have begged borrowed and steeled to try
to get on here so this is my lucky year
um yeah i'm really excited this is like
really really beautiful
i was going to ask if you knew drew one
of the things that uh
i've been fortunate to talk to him over
the years since he brought this here to
chattanooga from memphis is he always
seems to book people he likes
friends of his
uh well i would it seems like that yeah
he's good at creating like
a family kind of
yeah it does feel like i know a lot of
the bands i've written with some of the
artists
um i've hung out with them
we've talked about doing tours together
so that is pretty cool yeah you know it
is like it does feel like everyone's
connected which i think the i think
people feel that you know when they come
and they're the people are fans of each
other and they've
artists have toured together i think i
think so people feel that right yeah oh
definitely i feel it
yeah right
i mean that's the goal when you're like
going on tour you can just take out an
opener sometimes and it's like okay this
works
and it's definitely different than when
like there's a relationship and then the
people in the audience can feel that too
you know like
i i over the years i've interviewed uh
several of the bands at like winter jam
and i remember
some years ago talking to them and they
were like you know what we just decided
we're going to book people we like
if we're going to be around them for a
long time you know that's the thing yeah
the longer i do this
yeah i have really talented musicians in
my band but
i also
if we you gotta just like being around
people because you spend a lot of your
time on the road yeah those bus rides
can be long right yeah man if the if you
got that annoying just the person that's
not choosing to fit in with everyone
that's doesn't matter how good your
licks are you know that's right you're
like bro that's right 90 minutes or we
got 60 minutes we got the rest of the
time
we're angry we got 22 hours and 30
minutes we got to spend together outside
of that time yeah exactly right i wanted
to ask you um
about your career and and your career
arc really um
a lot of artists and musicians
grow and change and all that but one of
the things that
i thought uh was kind of interesting in
in
learning more about you and listening to
your music is
started out doing covers like i guess a
lot of people do and then sort of it
figured out what was working for you
right i mean
well i i want to go with your story but
actually i literally haven't can't play
covers and never have never so i don't
know yet wow no no i like it i wanted to
go there with you but no i literally
started writing music because i was so
bad at covers
i did well that's what i did there you
go yes i i didn't mean you were making a
living at it no but i mean no i mean as
in like i
um
i was an english major in college and
didn't start doing music until i was in
college really
and i was always good at writing and i
always knew that i could put words
together was kind of how i didn't
fail high school was if i had could
write a paper i could get through it so
my roommate had a guitar and i started
honestly i just would try to learn
whatever dave matthews was doing at the
time or somebody and i was like this is
too hard so i just play a couple chords
and say some stuff you know like three
chords in the truth was like kind of how
i started three chords on the truth
right you know i mean that's that was
the goal at least and
so to this day i still
we do a couple covers we'll maybe do one
tonight but
i'm they're hard for me because yeah
kind of a one-trick pony that is what i
i read and that's i just thought that
was interesting for you to figure it out
it's kind of like i always find it
fascinating how an artist
uh can realize what their talents are
maybe it's a voice they have a certain
voice you know they might want to try to
sing like otis redding but can't yeah
you know so you go with what you can do
right
i mean i totally artists i love and it's
probably because i'm one of them but i
tend to be drawn towards artists that
sometimes even have a limited
kind of skill set but they do it really
well you know like
johnny cash or bob dylan or yeah those
would be like even like i grew up with a
lot of you two and stuff like
the edge had his pedals and like he did
his thing and he you wouldn't put him in
on any session but bands like that were
like
they kind of do their thing and they
just stick to it
and
limitations sometimes become really
beautiful and so yes i i would
definitely put that in i am one of those
that was like i had these parameters i
was learning how to sing i knew i could
kind of use spoken word and some like
stories
but i couldn't lean on just my chops and
i had to
grow those as i've been touring over the
years but yeah the limitations are cool
i think um what people do interesting
things it's recognizing them and then
kind of working with it is where i was
going with this that sort of thing is
like i said i
i i know i've interviewed artists who
want to be doing something yes and then
they finally figure it out or or
whatever um yeah in your head
how do you think where do you think you
are uh
have you did you have that sort of
here's what i want to do ah i mean
here's what i
interesting like that is a really
interesting
question as in like
i think contentment is an interesting
journey
also it maybe speaks to what you're
talking about like
i all i do love the chase
me and my band always talk about this
are steve my drummer steve gould he's a
super talented drummer we we love to
like talk about the shows and analyze
them and we always have like a powwow
after the show and it's like this hunger
to kind of
what could we have done better or what
did we do that was awesome or just
we post show always talk about him and
he's like
you just kind of like the hunt don't you
like you don't even like the kill you
like the like journey of like searching
for something and like
um
so that is a very real thing in my own
life to a fault sometimes you're like
always yeah you're never just like hey
this is great and and i think the more
i've done this in my arc
um
yeah i think i am really
every day i get to do this i just feel
really grateful that i i'm doing music
my last job was like
i was a barista at starbucks you know
like that's this is pretty good so
uh
i think what i do and trying to do it
and being content with it is like
made me such a better
performer and i've enjoyed it so much
more i don't even know if that was your
question
it is i mean
it's just it's that it to me it's the
difference in the chase i guess i always
ask an artist
you know
how how they feel about the latest album
it sounds like such a
silly trite kind of question but does
anyone ever like oh i hate it it always
depends
i really no i i generally
um
i actually really love my last record
my newest one whatever it is january
flower it came out like an out i don't
know what a year ago maybe a year and a
half
but there is a funny thing where i
usually
dislike
there's a point when i usually dislike
my last record
and i like and i or i dislike a specific
record and it's funny how they always
change based on where i'm at
and that's maybe speaks to i love to
kind of do different things so one
record if one records one way i tend to
have a knee-jerk reaction to try to do
something that's like a little different
just for my own creative curiosity you
know like i was never
doing the same thing
you know and every time i've tried to
kind of chase something before it's
usually never successful so then i get
really frustrated with whatever those
moments are where you're like
oh you're trying to emulate that one
song that was really big and it never
works so it's always like
whenever you're swinging the other way
and like okay what are we just doing
because we love
i are always tend to be the moments that
um really resonate for a long time but
but it does change all the time like it
does and i've done this enough times
that i've interviewed bands multiple
times
so one album will be the you know over
produced we're going to spend yeah 12
months
doing everything and then the next one
we're going to go back to our roots and
do an acoustic set or a hard rock set or
something so it just
changes i think you have to have a
couple albums under your belt too before
you can like literally admit to yourself
as an artist that like oh i missed it on
that one because we know they got like
four records you can't be like right
right right a quarter of my career i was
a phony no or like
but i do think when you the longer you
do it you can look back and be like
those moments weren't as successful
um
and you can kind of figure out why like
oh maybe i was i was trying to yeah put
on a hat that didn't fit or i was trying
to listen to the audience too much or
management or producer had too much
power or did not enough power or i
wasn't listening to my band enough i
don't know you know there's
there is those interesting journeys you
have you look back at your projects and
um
and you like learn from them
that kind of gets to the question i
asked a little bit earlier in your head
how do you do you think you're
this is what you want
the yeah sound to be
i'm really proud of
yeah i think i really
i don't know how it's to do it then like
if you don't love it
yeah
your test market if your test market is
you in the studio
or with a guitar and if you don't love
it you're already starting like
it's like a dude making an ice cream for
an ice cream shop and he's like well i
think people like chocolate strawberry
and you taste you're like i don't really
like this yeah but people buy it like
that's that's not a good start you're
going to be like that's fair i love this
ice cream like you got to be like yo you
got to taste my ice cream this is the
best ice cream you ever had and if you
don't believe that
yeah you have to believe it yeah your
test market is not you're already a rick
rubin always says
if you don't love it you're already
starting in a deficit like
maybe someone else will like it
because you're doing something i don't
know i yeah i i don't
i just try to love it and
if you're if you're a big fan of it
you're
you also kind of can't lose because
you're doing something you love
and last question for me really what
does weather like this what does it do
dude
this is a we talk about the bonnaroo
experience yeah
you're you're camping you're committed
yeah you're in and the and the
artists seem to know that you know you
know you've got an audience that wants
to be there
that is committed that is yeah hardcore
does this things like days like this
does it sort of impact that at all or i
mean
what do we got we got some like overcast
definitely overcast a little wet what is
it 70
heat-wise
seventy-one yeah i i see now you're
talking to a kid i grew up in eugene
oregon good point so
this is like
this is a solid eight months of my year
so i am like this is actually
i i the one thing i like about this is
is the fatigue of like just heat like it
that's a it's a beat down for people
to be in we played hinterland this year
and it was a hundred it was the hottest
show ever played it was like in heat
index of 109
i and i ran out and
there was like i made this joke about
this tree that was like there's one tree
in the middle of the crowd and i was
like this is the most coveted tree
this tree has lived its whole life for
this ev everyone was in the shade it was
like it was literally like
like a refugee boat like stacked into
the
shade of this tree yeah and i i tried to
run out there to the tree and i
literally almost passed out which was a
terrible idea but um
i don't know something about this kind
of weather i find it comforting because
i'm used to overcast
and
like lights look better
like
you know there's like everybody's kind
of chilling there's like a little
melancholy yeah to it which i love i'm
like we're we could be here all day
you're not you
nice you could drink you don't have to
like drink 64 ounces of water or you'll
die kind of yeah yeah we're familiar
with that heat i've seen like the tree
where people would sit and line up and
as as the shadow moved they yeah they're
slowly slowly moving their way in yeah
man
i know this is beautiful i mean i was a
it's a little bit of a bummer when
you're when you're watching the radar
you're like i hope it doesn't rain like
pour when we're playing that's never fun
right but this feels pleasant i'm nice
i'm in it very cool
me too yeah if it stays like this all
day we're gonna be fine it's gonna be
great yeah great brush you have any
other questions i've dominated as i
always do fine yeah i think i think i'm
just looking forward to your set i love
it you're a westfalia you have a west
valley event yeah yeah he's got a
volkswagen shirt on russ with the bus
rest for the bus and uh i love it yeah
bring it to bonnaroo what year 1978 78
yeah year i was born the year before
don't tell anybody
it's got the bed up yeah it's pop top
camper the rooftop tent um couch
everything my first car was a 68
squareback
my dad let me buy it was like they kind
of look like a station wagon yeah but
they're little yeah it's a they're like
a little tiny station i had a a notch
back which was this yeah those are cool
cars was mine was a fastback oh you're
the fastest we had them all covered all
three yeah
there was one other one too i think they
did for do you the
there was one year where they had
another one i thought that was a weird
one uh the fastback was rounded yeah
that much back was like the sedan yes
and then we did those in the us they had
to be imported that okay those are the
ones that are hard to get they're real
hard those are like the
yeah i was awesome i drove it i
ran out of oil
one day
and we had to
yeah it was bad well ours we had a
driveway that went up a hill
and
i don't remember it was me and my
brother didn't know how to do clutch
very well so it got stuck halfway up
and we had to get a neighbor to come
love it yeah we learned
matt thank you so much for your time man
always a pleasure yeah it's part of your
set and uh it's a pleasure to meet you
and and i appreciate you giving us so
much time honor to be here all right
thank you guys
[Music]
yeah there you go so that was matt
carney uh like i said really nice guy
right i enjoyed talking to him i did too
i i would hang out with him all day
yeah i got the feeling that once the
microphone's off he he wanted to talk
some more vw
he kind of did yeah yeah
nice guy and it was a really fun show
like i said it was surprised me i
i had listened to some of his music and
i i thought it was a little more
uh spoken word sort of rap oriented but
it was very much uh
a lot of vocals and the band was was
very prominent and
like we said the the paul simon uh
call me owl was uh totally unexpected
it was and i think his his show was one
of my highlights of the weekend yeah i
agree
i didn't even ask you that yeah what was
what was your highlight
i would say him and briston were up
there um natalie himby was also really
good um
saturday or sunday sammy ray um she was
really good and
for her two songs and i was excited
because i was like oh we're about to go
you know interview her and then of
course it got scrapped so i felt bad for
her that
her set got cut short but she was able
to go and perform at the memorial that
night
when they announced the the makeup
concert so yeah she she got to
i'm sure she had a great time there too
i have a feeling and that's why i i
i think that's why i reached out to you
monday morning and uh
kept pushing i have a feeling this is
going to be one of these events that
we're going to talk about for a long
long time so i think so and i think
those bands they were all so nice
um
you know the ones that were we were
supposed to talk to on sunday they were
reaching out saying hey are we still
doing this so i have a feeling
you know
maybe not tomorrow not next week
but it'll it'll happen so
at some point and who knows some of
these people you might see on the vanru
lineup in a year or two absolutely and
hopefully they will they will remember
that we tried to talk to them so i hope
so
all right all right man well thanks it
was great hanging out and uh
great hanging out thank you
yeah i'm glad to be back yeah yeah we've
kind of been on a little hiatus but
want to get back into it we got a lot to
talk about so i think you're exactly
subscribe if you're not already a lot of
changes going on so yeah subscribe and
yeah hit the like and all that other
stuff you're supposed to do
please do yeah all right thanks guys
okay
[Music]
[Music]
consequence podcast network